durante los seis meses que preceden la
primera vuelta de las elecciones en
francia está prohibida la propaganda
visual relativa a los candidatos o les
contienen este artículo del código
electoral no siempre se respeta al pie
de la letra pero quienes lo violen
pueden recibir multas de hasta nueve mil
euros el derecho a colgar imágenes en
los candidatos en público está reservado
a las autoridades de cada ciudad y se
permite sólo cuando inicia oficialmente
la campaña electoral en este caso el 28
de marzo a partir de entonces las
alcaldías están obligadas a instalar
estos paneles metálicos a razón de uno
por candidato a la presidencia sus
dimensiones son exactamente iguales y
deben estar ubicados al lado o al frente
de los lugares de votación el orden en
que aparecen se determina en un sorteo
realizado por el consejo constitucional
de la nación en algunos casos los
afiches son víctimas de la pasión de
algunos electores como aquí pero
atención vandalizar o arrancar
cualquiera de estos afiches pueden ser
penados con multas de hasta 750 euros
de esta forma se organiza la propaganda
electoral en lugares públicos su
objetivo garantizar la equidad de
exposición de todos los candidatos